Our first guest wrote in with a special request.
Ruby Ortiz is an 11th-grade Spanish teacher in Brooklyn,
but today, she's putting down the textbooks and picking up
the microphone to be our co-host for the day.
Ruby, welcome.
(audience applauds)
Thank you.
Thanks so much.
Well, Drew, I am really excited to be here.
I love watching your show after a long day of work.
I mean, I love your Stan for Stains segment.
You've helped me remove so many stains.
I love it.
You host so many fabulous celebrities.
I love to be here.
I hope that by being here,
I can show my students that you can do anything
you put your mind to,
and I'm excited to get started and ready to be here.
(audience applauds)
Well, we sent you home last night
with a whole bunch of what we call dossiers,
which just sounds like Oprah Winfrey meets the FBI.
(audience laughs)
It's like on our show,
we have a lot of information on everyone who comes.
Everything goes into these dossiers.
So we gave you our homework packet last night.
You did.
I'm ready.
I've studied my notes, and I'm ready for today.
All right, then you and me both.
All right, well let's head over
to the news desk to hit the headlines.
(upbeat music)
(audience applauds)
Okay, it's time for Drew's News,
your daily tip of the good news cap.
And with me at the desk is one of the finest fellows
in news, Ross Mathews.
Hi.
Hi, everybody.
(audience applauds)
Hi, Drew.
(Ross laughs)
Oh, this is so fun.
I love kicking off the show with the news.
I know, and we got a lot to talk about today.
So here we go.
First up, fans of the classic horror movie franchise
Halloween are freaking out,
because the new movie comes out Friday.
Ooh.
I know. Halloween Kills stars the legendary
scream queen, Jamie Lee Curtis,
and of course the always creepy Michael Myers.
(audience laughs)
No one's more excited than a little
four-year-old girl named Aria.
She recently went viral,
because she was simply over the moon
when Michael Myers crashed her birthday.
What?
(audience laughs)
Look at this.
Yeah. She loves him, apparently-
(Ross groans)
and he's her favorite character.
I don't know how in the hell she
found out about him in the first place, but yeah.
(Ross groans)
Rossy, what would you do if Michael Myers
showed up to your birthday?
I'd be chucking cupcakes,
is what I be doing.
Get out of here.
(audience laughs)
You know I don't like scary movies, okay.
The scariest movie I ever watched was Mrs. Doubtfire.
I don't like anything worse than that.
(Drew laughs)
(audience laughs)
This little girl, can we get her a Barney?
Something.
This is freaky.
No, ma'am.
No, no.
(audience laughs)
Well, do you know what's really funny-
What?
is my daughter Frankie loves "It".
That movie, "It"?
Well, not the movie, because
I don't want her to watch the movie.
What is "It"?
It's that clown who is a killer.
(blows raspberries)
Out, timeout, got to go.
Nope, nope!
(audience laughs)
And she knows he's dark, but she also loves cemeteries.
She's a little macabre.
You know what I mean?
Oh, God.
Ruby, are you a horror movie fan?
I'm not.
I'm with Ross.
I am not a fan.
Yeah.
I can't sit through a scary movie.
I'm jumping every five seconds.
I can't.
My heart's racing.
Ruby and I'll be in the corner watching
Pretty Woman on a loop.
Yes we will.
Thank you.
(Ruby laughs)
(audience laughs)
Thank you.
Yes we will.
Well, speaking of Halloween classics,
Tim Burton's "The Nightmare Before Christmas",
have you seen it?
(audience cheers)
Well, then you're in luck.
It's going to be turned into a
live concert film event this month.
And People reports that the
beloved character of Sally will be performed
by none other than Billie Eilish.
My favorite!
(audience cheers)
Right?
My favorite.
Great casting.
My hero.
My favorite.
Yeah, she's going to be phenomenal in this,
and she'll perform with the incredible Danny Elfman,
reprising Jack Skellington.
And you've seen this, right?
You like "Nightmare Before Christmas"?
I do love this movie.
Big Tim Burton fan.
I would say my favorite Tim Burton movie
probably still to this day is "Edward Scissorhands".
Oh, yes.
And "Beetlejuice".
I love "Beetlejuice".
I auditioned for Beetlejuice.
Wait, time out.
You auditioned for "Beetlejuice"?
Oh, I audition for everything.
The main character, Winona?
Yes.
Wow.
I have auditioned for every movie out there.
Really?
(audience laughs)
Absolutely.
Oh, I have so many more questions.
When I was a kid, yeah.
What one killed you the most that you didn't get?
Gosh, that's a good question.
I don't know.
(stammers)
I mean, I auditioned for "Cape Fear".
Oh.
I told that story.
Yeah.
That's what happens.
You know, you just try out for everything.
Well, I'm still upset
they didn't cast me as James Bond, but you know what?
I move on.
(Drew laughs)
(audience laughs)
Got over it.
(Drew laughs)
I should say yet.
They haven't cast me yet as James Bond.
They're looking for a new one, Rossy.
That's a double "Oh no."
(Drew laughs)
(audience laughs)
Well, we've got some good news
from the golden arches in today's Green News.
(audience applauds)
I'm very excited about this.
PBS reports that McDonald's has made a pledge
to drastically cut the use of plastics in
Happy Meal toys.
Yes!
I love this!
(audience applauds)
By 2025, they will use 90% less plastic,
and they're already phasing in toys
made of cardboard and plant-based plastics.
And also by 2025, all of their food packaging
will be in sustainable and fully-recyclable boxes.
(audience applauds)
Oh, this is great.
I say this a lot, but I'm going to keep saying it.
I am scared that we will not make this deadline
to save our planet.
And when the big companies step in and say
they're going to make the changes, I get hopeful.
Yeah.
Because we have to make our individual efforts,
but it feels futile when the big companies
are doing it a different way.
So thank you, McDonald's.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
I very much, as one citizen, really appreciate it.
Yeah, I do too.
And I have to say,
I was a little hesitant though,
because this is great that they're doing this,
but here's a nugget of advice, McDonald's.
You got to keep them cool.
Right?
Because when I was a little kid,
I would go to town on a Happy Meal for that toy.
And I have to say, we have some of them right here.
Well done, McDonald's.
They're cool, all right?
Look at this.
It's cute.
It's all paper.
I'd be excited about this.
Listen, this is just good news.
I'm into it.
Me too, yeah.
But just keep them cool like this, okay?
This is cool.
Or I'm hitting Burger King on the way home.
Got it?
(audience laughs)
Well, we have a new segment alert.
We're trying something brand new today.
We asked you what we should review,
and we got so many good responses.
So now it's time for the first-ever installment
of Drew's Reviews.
(synth sounds)
(audience cheers)
Oh, it's warm.
I swear, Ross is going to kill me.
Every-
Every day I show up,
there's a different carbohydrate here
waiting for us to eat.
I am trying to keep it together, Drew.
I know.
I'm sorry.
And I was on a diet too,
and now, oh gosh.
Well, what are you going to do?
Come on.
Well, today, our pick comes from
Rachael Oseland on Instagram.
It's Trader Joe's Pumpkin Caramel Kringle.
Now, apparently, the kringle is a Trader Joe's specialty,
but only during this special time of year
can you get it in the pumpkin flavor.
By the way, I'm salivating.
Okay, okay.
How much did you eat?
Did you lick it, Rossy?
Did you take a lady bite?
(audience laughs)
I took a petite nibble, thank you very much.
I took a giant mouthful of it.
You know what it's giving me in a great way?
Like maple bar.
It's giving me cinnamon roll.
Yeah, it's like the two of those mated.
I'm not mad about it.
Yeah, this is really good.
Thank you so much, Rachael,
for asking us to try yet another
delicious tasty treat here on the news.
You know, I guess if you're doing a review,
you should rate it.
All right.
How do you wanna do it?
I think it's like...
What is it, five stars is the best?
(audience laughs)
I'm going to go four and a half.
Whoa.
Yeah, this is good.
(audience applauds)
That's a big review.
It's so wonderful.
All right, well please, please, please
write in new reviews.
We'd love to try fun stuff and give it a review.
We'll be right back.
(upbeat music)